the widespread cyber risk of a remote
workforce and how companies and
individuals can be better protected when
working from home in tonight's cyber
safe parent
working from home provided a new gateway
for cyber thieves with the fbi reporting
a 400 percent increase in cyber attacks
in the first months of the pandemic
especially for a lot of these smaller
businesses you know these mom pop shops
they're using what's called remote
desktop protocol basically setting up a
pipeline to use your home computer to
remote into your work computer problem
with that is if you don't have the right
firewalls in place which most small
businesses don't it makes it really easy
for hackers
and ransomware thieves to to be able to
compromise the network inadequate cyber
security can be addressed by firewalls
and anti-virus scanning but rushed or
distracted employees make mistakes
one wrong click can threaten the digital
safety of a company thieves intercept
communications to get at the privileged
content the accounting and client data
once these cyber thieves have your
personal identifying information it's
really easy for them to just own your
identity and destroy your life
financially another issue can be the
speedy development of apps some might
not have reinforcements in place to keep
users safe generally speaking if you go
with you know some some larger name
companies they're generally investing
more info more of their their money into
having that what we call i.t security
infrastructure that is having good
firewalls and strong mechanisms in place
if employees are working with names
dates of birth confidential financial
data experts say that still might best
be done inside the walls of the office
and not be sharing that you know via
email or as attachments or things like
that where it's easier for it to be
intercepted by cyber thieves one quarter
of all employees have noticed an
increase in fraudulent emails spam
phishing attempts in their work email
since the beginning of kovid's shutdowns
two years later some are still working
from home
cyber security professionals greatly
needed cyber security is one of the
fastest growing fields
and right now a lot of employers both
public sector and private sector they
can't even fill the spots fast enough